دعت ست منظمات دوليه معنيه بالحقوق
والحريات الصحفيه اداره بايدن الى تحرك
فوري وصارم لضمان حمايه واحترام حقوق
الصحفيين الذين يغطون الحرب في غزه وعبرت
هذه المنظمات عن صدمتها لمقتل عدد كبير من
الصحفيين خلال فتره وجيزه ووجهت لجنه
حمايه الصحفيين وبيت الحريه ومؤسسه حريه
الصحافه ومراسل بلا حدود وهيوم رايتس وتش
ومعهد نايت التابع لجامعه كولومبيا وجهت
الرئيس جو بايدن في رساله مشتركه الى دعوه
جميع الاطراف الى احترام حق الصحفيين في
تغطيه الاعمال القتاليه وضمان سلامتهم
وتجنب استهدافهم بشكل متعمد او عشوائي
والتحقيق في الهجمات التي تعرض لها
الصحفيون ومحاسبه المسؤولين
عنها ينضم الينا من شيكاجو عمر شاكر مدير
منظمه هيوم رايتس وتش في اسرائيل
وفلسطين سيد شاكر انتم من المنظمات التي
وجهت هذه الرساله لبايدن بتقدير هل ستغير
شيئا هذه الرساله من السياسه المعتمده من
قبل الولايات
المتحده ان سياسات الاداره الامريكيه شكلت
اشكاليه لسنوات ولعقود من الزمن والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لم تستخدم الاوراق التي
لديها من اجل كبح الفضاءات التي ترتكبها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان قتل الصحفيين 79
صحفيا في عره اسابيع وفقا لمنظمه او لجنه
حمايه الصحفيين العدد هو في خلال عشر
اسابيع اكثر من اي سنه في اي بلد من العمل
لعقد من الزمن وش وثقت القتل المتعمد من
قبل السلطات الاسرائيليه للصحفيين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها قدره
على التاثير بشكل كبير على اسرائيل ويتعين
عليها ان تستخدم هذه القدره لحمايه
الصحفيين سيد شاكر فيما تتحدثون عن
الاوراق التي لم تستخدمها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه للضغط على اسرائيل
بلينكن يقول ان واشنطن تضغط باستمرار على
اسرائيل تجنب سقوط ضحايا مدنيين كيف
تنظرون الى ما يقوله بلينكن في ضوء هذه
الرساله التي وجهتها الى
بايدن في الحقيقه واقع الحال هو ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتحدث عن
ضروره احترام القانون الانساني الدولي
وبلينك ذهب الى دوله قطر وعبر عن تعازيه
لعائله السيد الد حدوه بعد مقتل اعضاء
اسرته وقصف منزله ولكن حتى الان يتعين
علينا ان نرى او لم نرى بعد الادانه
الحقيقيه حتى بعد مقتل شرين ابو عقله ما
حصل في غزه وما حصل في لبنان بعد السابع
من اكتوبر وفيما بعد الادانه نحن بحاجه
الى خطوات للتاكد من التحقق والتحقيق في
هذه الحوادث ومحاسبه
وان
الصحفيين يحترم حقوق هؤلاء ويسمح للصحفيين
الدوليين بدخول الى قطاع غزه بشكل امن وان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحكومه
الولايات المتحده يمكنها ان تستخدم
الاوراق التي لديها من خلال المساعدات
العسكريه والادوات
المختلفه امين
بكل تاكيد الاداه الاهم التي هي بحوزه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي المساعدات
العسكريه 3.7 او 8 مليارات دولار بالسنه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه سرعت عمليه
ارسال الاسلحه الى اسرائيل طبعا يجب على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تفرض حظرا
للاسلحه على اسرائيل طالما ترتكب اسرائيل
هذه الجرائم والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يمكنها ان تستخدم اوراق اخرى من خلال مجلس
الامن الذي يستخدم الغطاء او يشكل الغطاء
السياسي والدبلوماسي لاسرائيل طبعا هناك
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ومحكمه العدل
الدوليه التي هي من ضمن اختصاصاتها ان
تنظر بهذه الجرائم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لديها ادوات متعدده ولكن ما
يمنع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو غياب
النيه السياسيه